[MUSIC]
Good afternoon.
Welcome back.
Would you all do me a small favor?
Yeah?
Thank you, thank you.
Would you, I know you just got settled,
would you all just stand up and
find a new seat?
Any seat but the one you're in.
Perfect.
>> Oh, perfect.
Thank you very much.
I didn't see any fights, so that was good.
And you all successful at it,
of course we're at Stanford.
Now I'd like you to have a short
conversation with someone nearby,
maybe not the person you came with,
or maybe it's them,
15 or
20 seconds on what allowed you to do that.
What were all of the gestures and
facial expressions and everything
that happened, no matter how small.
Like you were a scientist.
What did you notice that helped
you to get to the new seat
without getting into a fight?
>> [LAUGH]
>> 15 or 20 seconds,
talk to the people nearby.
All right, great.
Good.
Give a little thank you to
your discussion partner.
Say thank you to your discussion partner.
Great.
So, you are all already experts
at what I'm talking about today.
So we're just a room full of experts.
We're talking about power and
the language of power.
It's the secret language we all speak.
Throughout that interaction,
you didn't run into each other.
You didn't fall over each other.
You negotiated.
Somebody had to decide who gives way and
goes by, and who doesn't.
And there's a lot of smiling, and
nodding, and head tilting,
that happens all throughout.
I was watching, not everyone of you,
but I saw a lot of you.
And that's what happening.
That is the secret language of
power that we speak all the time.
So, how many of you want power?
Raise your hand nice and
tall if you want power.
Oh, yes!
Yes, I teach in the business school and
I know this.
Yeah, we're captains of industry.
We want power.
Not every hand though.
How many of you, not really trying to
grasp all that power and amass it?
There's the friendly, nice people.
I see your smiles, yeah.
So we're kind of split.
I think the most interesting
question is why do we want power?
Or why do we not want power?
because it has different meanings.
Now, if we had a larger, huge, huge table,
we could all sit around one big table and
have a nice discussion about it.
But since we can't,
let me pull some discussion
pieces from a few famous people.
Contact with men who wield power and
authority still leaves
an intangible sense of repulsion.
It's very much like being in
proximity to fecal matter.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Now that is an opinion about power
and that some of you not wanting power
might share some of that sentiment.
But some people have a different opinion.
I love power.
>> [LAUGH]
>> But it is an artist that I love it.
I love it as a musician loves his violin,
to draw its sounds and
chords and harmonies.
This guy loves power.
He really wants it, but
those are opposing positions.
How can it be that we love power and
we hate power.
Well, why are we averse to it?
For one thing, people do not always
acquire power for the right reasons.
And right is a perspective, because your
right reason to acquire power might not be
the same as other people, so
there's some discrepancy.
But there are definitely people
that pretty universally we can say
try to amass power for the wrong reasons.
Because they often misuse it and
it's not pretty.
Now we can go back in history and
see some really terrible things that have
happened when people have mass power.
But we can look in the paper today and
see that that is still going on.
There is struggle for power,
and there are negative consequences, and
that's part of why we're adverse to it.
We don't want anybody to have too much so
they don't start doing bad things.
And we believe in meritocracy, generally.
We learn it in school.
The right answer should be
the thing that prevails.
I mean that's just right, isn't it?
Somewhere deep down we know that little
third grader in all of us is like,
no that's not right!
It shouldn't be that way.
They have the right answer.
So we kind of have an aversion to power.
But at the same time we also want
power because we know, we recognize,
there's a time when you need it.
Especially when that is in service
of the greater good or someone else.
And as a leader of people,
an organization,
a team, a group of children,
whatever it is.
There is a time when you
need to wield that power
in a way that helps to serve them.
And I don't think we would disagree
with wanting that kind of power.
Power to keep people safe.
Power to help them achieve what they want.
Those are great uses of power.
I think we would all sign up for,
yes, I like power.
I want it in that case.
And we definitely covet status.
We want people to respect us.
We do everything we can to
stay off the bottom and
make sure there's at least
that one person that's below.
>> [LAUGH]
>> There are videos and things
that show the buckets of crabs, where
they're all clawing each other back down.
Not really clawing their way up, but
at least putting somebody below.
And sometimes work can feel that
way if it's not a great situation.
But we definitely don't
want to be the bottom.
And we fight pretty hard.
And it happens from a very young age,
we start learning it in schools,
navigating this social hierarchy.
And that's what we're talking about today.
That first exercise you did, of get up and
move around, and then have a discussion
about it, is part of a body of work
that is in the class, Acting With Power.
So I'm a lecturer in the organizational
behavior department and
there is an amazing team that I get
to work with that teach this class.
And we have all contributed
the ideas I'm sharing today.
What I can tell you is I believe
all of them, and with conviction.
And I do this work all around the world.
But that class works in
the way that you just did it.
We throw the students into an activity,
unexperienced,
where they're not quite sure why
they're doing it or what's going on.
It feels a little strange and
then we ask them to reflect on it.
And then, we come back and say,
let's put some thought behind it.
Let's pull some of the research and
try to explain what's going on.
Now, it's a beautiful
marriage between art and
science because the science says,
this is why it's happening.
But the art side, the doing it and
the experience,
discovers the truths we all know.
And it lets us feel
what's really happening.
So that we know it empirically,
and it's nice to know why.
So that is what this class
is about that I teach.
And that is what we're talking about today
and what you are already experts in.
Come on in, find a seat.
Yeah, there's some right here.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Great.
>> [INAUDIBLE].
>> No, no it's fine.
It's a great example because they
all know what you're doing now.
>> [LAUGH]
>> They all just got up and moved and
changed seats.
>> [INAUDIBLE]
>> [LAUGH] Okay, so, why do we have
this love/hate relationship with power?
Well, as we all know, when relationships
are challenging, you have to have that,
define the relationship conversation.
So let's have a definition
conversation about power.
What is power?
Power means a lot of things to a lot of
people, and we use it in various ways.
So if we're going to actually have
some rigorous discussion about it,
we define it.
You do not have to adopt these, but for
the sake of how we're talking about it
today, these are how I'm
going to talk about it.
Power's the capacity to control
resource and administer consequence.
Pretty simple.
Resource can be anything.
It could be money, it could be time,
it could be schedule.
It could be responsibility.
It could be friendship and social.
You have power over someone
when they depend on you.
For things that are important to them,
and in your control.
Or, things that they cannot
easily get other places.
Parents control the candy.
It is something that is important to
the children and in the parents' control.
And the children, up to a certain age,
cannot get easily on their own.
But there's a balancing equation,
because children control
the audible space in the house.
>> [LAUGH]
>> It is something important
to the parents and in control of the
children, and that they cannot easily get
other places, because they
have to stay and tend to them.
So, there is a balance back and
forth that shows up in every relationship.
Authority, on the other hand,
sounds like power.
It's similar.
It's in the same playing field.
Authority is a characteristic
of a formal role.
So, the right and responsibility to
control, direct, and dominate others.
Here is your title, you are the vice
president in charge of this.
You get to control that,
we official mandate that you do,
it's part of your role.
It's your formal title.
It is a basis of power, but
it may give you control over resources.
You may have seen a person or
two who had the title but
didn't really control resources.
They're ineffectual.
People don't listen to them.
So it's not just authority.
Hopefully, it's not too many of
these people that are out there.
But it does come up.
But if that is not the only thing,
if the title doesn't absolutely give you
the control, there must be something else.
And in social science we call it status,
the extent to which others
hold you in high esteem.
Are you respected?
And that is a way you
can control resource.
It's a condition or a relationship and
it's a basis of power.
But people on an equal team,
one person can lead that team and
everyone will defer because
of the known expert.
Maybe it's the best football player or
the person that knows math
the best in the study group.
And everyone will defer to them.
They suggest that we run a play or
that we study on this set of problems.
And people will listen.
They control the resource
of what's happening.
So, power can be derived by authority or
from status.
That seems pretty simple.
So there's our definition
of the relationships there.
One of these is not very
much in your control.
It's hard to give yourself a promotion.
If you can do it, I recommend it.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Go ahead and do it now.
But, because you usually can't define it,
you need help from other people.
Status is the one that we can play with,
and that's the one totally in our control.
That's how we interoperate and
relate to other people.
So we can get power just
by changing who we are.
And that's kind of a hopeful story,
as far as I'm concerned.
Now, when we talk about power.
Controlling resources, there's that
love hate thing that comes back in.
Whose controlling it, and
what are they using it for?
So, the goal of this work is to
expand the authentic range in this
equation of how you show up in your
status with power, status, and
authority, because it's about
improving relationships.
Communicating better.
And as a leader, and the students
that we have coming through here,
we want them to go out and be effective.
And to lead and build good relationships.
Now you can use all of these tools that
we're going to talk about for evil.
They're just tools.
You can influence other people,
you can amass power and you can use it for
good or evil.
But, our contention is, that if you can
successfully navigate conversations
better, if you can build relationships and
prune them in how you operate with people,
you can change the world.
You can change organizations and you can
accomplish your leadership goals and
change the way you coach and you mentor
and you facilitate and you lead.
That is a worthy goal in understanding
the non-verbal communication and
social hierarchies.
At the end of the day,
it allows you to show up in the way
that your stakeholders need you to.
Your audience.
And your audience is the people
below you in the organization.
The people on the team that
you're trying to bring along.
The non-profit that you work with and
you're on a board.
How can you help to influence them,
build a bond, get respect, and
move things forward for
the goals that you have?
because if your intention is good,
we want to help you move along that route.
So, power.
I think this encapsulates the whole
idea I was telling you about.
The day that the power of love
overrules the love of power,
the world will know peace.
That's a little higher than
we shoot in the class.
>> [LAUGH]
>> But not too much higher,
because change lives and
change the world is in the motto.
We really are about how can you,
in your way as a leader,
use love as the basis of leadership,
which sounds a little funny.
But at the end of the day,
it's about people.
And that is a nice principle too,
love can take a lot of forms.
Love can be, just in service.
And if you can be in service
of people as a leader, and
use these tools in that way,
it's a very powerful place to be.
Okay, so, this secret language,
we're talking about, is universal.
Can you tell which one is on top here?
>> [LAUGH]
>> It's very clear.
Does anybody think that this tiger leaning
back is the one that's in control or
in power?
Right.
Plain, 100%, perfect.
Good.
Next question on the quiz.
It scales to any size.
So it doesn't really matter what
size you are, same thing here.
Who has the power?
I'm a dog person so
I like this one a little bit better.
But this is what's going on.
There is a whole language that
is being spoken here, and
I see this play out at
the dog park all the time.
There are books on wolf signaling
that explain these things,
and I will go and play with this because
it works across species as well.
And it doesn't matter if you're young or
old.
That puppy is clearly dominant.
He's so fierce, or she is.
But this how we learn it.
Because at a very young we start playing
with these tools with our friends,
with our parents, and
we build these social skills.
It's in the fabric of who we are and
how we operate.
This is how we communicate and
there's no intellectual study
going on in this equation.
This is just learning how do we respond to
the world and this is about relationships.
The interesting thing is that this
also governs our friendships.
They're playing with status,
who's on top and who isn't, but
that's how you define a friendship.
Friendships are the ones
where you can play with this.
You can put them down a little bit.
You can call out like there's that story
you know about your best friend that you
keep trotting out especially
after a glass of wine you're
like oh what about
the incident with the car.
And everybody knows what that is.
It's putting that person down and
saying, yeah you're a really bad driver.
That's really what you're saying.
But it's okay because it's in
this friendly and playful way.
If you have a relationship with someone
where you've known them a long time,
but they never felt like a friend,
I can never hit that level.
There's something different.
It's probably that the status
has never changed.
It's a static condition.
So it scales.
We learned it when we were young.
It goes cross-species.
And not just cross-species there but
cross-species here.
So this is universal stuff
that we're talking about.
It's dominance and submission.
So there is no, oh, that's not how
it works for me, or, I'm from this
region of the country, or this part of the
world, so we don't operate in that way.
This is really basic.
How it shows up has cultural differences,
to be sure.
And it's not about age, and
this is just gratuitously cute.
But, That little girl is the one
who's dominant over that
dog who clearly is a more
powerful animal in that equation.
Could cause harm, but doesn't.
It's giving respect.
That its status.
This is showing an esteem.
And it pretty much all comes
down to who bites who.
If you are high status or
coming in with that dominance,
you're saying stay away or
I will bite you.
And if you're submissive you're saying
don't bite me, I'm not worth biting.
It's pretty simple when it
gets down to the basics.
All right.
You can imagine your favorite or
least favorite politician here.
I wanted to stay pretty
neutral on this because
I have no idea whose who in audience.
So, you will see it in
politics all the time though.
We are at a really interesting part
of time where over the next year and
it's already been going on for a year.
But over the next year,
we're going to see the debates and
a ton of press going on around
the political election.
And there is so much that happens
in there that you can watch this.
If somebody does the handshake wrong,
adds the extra arm grab,
doesn't do the handshake or does a toast
where they don't look at each other
right, it's 24 hours on CNN.
It's 24 hours on CNN because it
means something to all of us.
It's not up there because
we don't understand it.
It's up there because we do understand it.
It says something and
it says something very clear,
and it's this language of power.
So it's going on all the time.
Okay.
>> Anybody know what this is?
>> Someone walking.
>> Someone walking?
Huh.
Technically it is 16 dots.
>> [LAUGH]
>> But, the 16 dots do come from
a person in a black suit with
lightbulbs on them, that they record.
In fact this is the aggregate
of 300 people doing that.
16 dots of information is a very very
small amount but you all saw a person.
I've never heard anything
other than that but
I suppose there could be a dog up
right perhaps, but it's a person.
You're really good at this because
somewhere along the line evolutionary
biology said you better be
good at recognizing humans and
taking stock of who they are,
are they friend or foe.
So we can recognize it very easily
with not a lot of information.
So just imagine what you get from
all 88 muscles that show up here and
all that extra information.
Gestures, all of that comes in.
Okay so that's a person, what about that?
>> [INAUDIBLE]
>> A soldier, what was that?
>> A male, oh a man.
Oh, okay what about this?
[LAUGH]
No
one ever laughs at the man,
everyone laughs at the woman.
[LAUGH] I don't know what that is but
here they are together.
They are definitely different.
What do you notice as
the differences specifically?
What was that?
>> [INAUDIBLE]
>> Sorry a little louder.
>> The hips move on the one on the right,
yeah?
What else?
The feet are closer together on this one?
The knees are?
>> [INAUDIBLE]
>> What was that?
>> The head moves less back and
forth on this one.
Oh on that one?
>> [INAUDIBLE]
>> The shoulders and
arms are more aggressive on this one.
The arms are moving more and
they are moving opposite.
Interesting, huh?
So, these are also averages and
then tuning out certain characteristics.
There is a tool that they have
that you can move some sliders.
And this is moving the male and
female slider to the extremes.
So some things that you pointed out like
the feet are very together on this one.
And the arms are a little more in and
the hips move.
Six and
seven year old girls do not walk this way.
Not in general, and
neither do female athletes going
out to play soccer out here.
This is learned behavior.
This is something that we adapt to,
for very particular reasons.
There is a lot of signalling and
cues that go on to this and
what it says, but
it is a learned behavior.
It's not innate.
Turns out, nine and 10-year-old boys
do not have any kind of muscle mass that
requires their arms to be out like this.
>> [LAUGH]
>> But
that's when they start to move their arms.
They're mimicking.
So we are being trained to become what
these are, this version of masculine or
feminine, from a very early age.
I don't think there's anything
intrinsically wrong with that, and
there's definitely some
biology reasons behind that.
And you know, the muscles do fill out for
some people, I guess.
>> [LAUGH]
>> And in high heels,
I think this comes up
even a little bit more.
But some other kind of shoes.
When you're out power walking,
it doesn't happen as much.
So it's something that we don't always do.
But it is a certain piece of how we
start to learn this language of power.
What's the right thing for me to be and
how I show up in a different context?
I'm not advocating that it should
be any way, one or the other.
And there is clearly, in this work,
a couple of things that
are very deep holes that we can
just go down into for a long time.
This could all be about gender and we've
got some really good data about gender,
but I want to keep it just a little bit
up out of that particular one for now.
I avoided politics I think
rather nicely as well.
>> [LAUGH]
>> So here's different.
This is not male/ female.
What do you think of this one?
>> Michael Jackson.
>> Michael Jackson!
>> [LAUGH]
>> I have never heard that but I love it.
What else?
I'm going to start that one again.
>> [INAUDIBLE]
>> Happy?
Running.
Power walker?
Determined?
With purpose.
Okay, what about this one?
>> [LAUGH]
>> The right side is always funnier.
I don't know why.
What about this one?
>> What was it?
>> Suave, yeah, suave.
>> [LAUGH]
>> I'm pretending like
I know what it means too.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Yeah I think I'm not suave.
They're different yeah?
>> That person doesn't know.
>> That one doesn't know how to walk.
>> [INAUDIBLE]
[LAUGH]
>> Yes, yeah.
They are moving their
knees a little like this.
But I think that is a function of
the averaging, not any one individual.
But that is true.
So this one, the slider that gets
moved is nervous and relaxed.
So nervous has energy, so
power walk I think lines up with that.
They didn't have power walk on there,
but they had nervous and energy.
And then as it turns out,
you can rotate and watch from the side.
Now during this one,
I am dynamically am moving the sliders.
I'll narrate it.
This is normal.
Then I slide to male.
Then I slide to female.
Yeah, longer stride.
You can see the hips swing
from the side as well.
Interesting huh?
I have heard more than once that part
of the reason of this in the angle is
the high heels.
Is that true?
Yeah, that is true.
That bears out in my reasearch
which is informal, but
almost every audience tells me that.
So we're very good.
All of your observations,
accurate for sure.
It looks like something, and
we're good at recognizing what it is.
This is all that language of power that is
the secret language going on all the time.
Hopefully you're recognizing this and
you're going, oh, yeah, I recognize this.
This isn't new.
You go to a cocktail party, circle of
people, and someone approaches and
the circle usually does one of two things.
It opens up and it lets them in,
or it closes ranks and it doesn't.
And that is the same thing.
It's about who we're protecting that
we're going to allow and share our power.
And just one person in that group
can sort of own the space and
the power that they have, and
invite them and say, come, join us, and
bring them into their space and
bend part of the circle.
So we can act individually as agents and
change this equation and
affect relationships.
But it's something that's familiar.
And we know it, we learn it the hard
way in junior high school, primarily.
There's a lot of social dynamic and
we try and experiment and fail.
And it's a lovely, awkward, awful time.
But it's where we sort out most of
this and then we sort of get set and
we learn our way.
This is how I navigate the world.
And we're somewhere on this spectrum.
>From this sort of powerful, high place
to this low and more approachable place.
This is the reference for
this is a university in Canada, and so we
can see male and female; we did heavy and
light, nervous, relaxed, happy, and sad.
And it's just pulling averaging out.
They have a lot more information if you're
interested to go and dig in on that,
the Biomotion Lab.
So your turn.
Let's try this.
Think about the day of the month
that your birthday is on.
For me it's the 7th of July,
so my number is seven.
Think of what your number of the month is.
If you are an even numbered day,
you're going to be team blue.
Just remember, I'm team blue right now.
If you're an odd numbered person,
just remember that you're green.
Blue and green.
And if you forget,
just pick one it doesn't really matter.
But I want it about half and half.
All right, I'm going to ask you,
you don't have to move.
You don't have to change positions.
But if you would, stand up, because
I want you to be able to look around.
You're getting off easy, by the way.
Our classes are a lot more active.
I was trying to give you a nice
soft reentry into your schooling.
So, all right.
Team blue.
I want, I'm going to ask you, I'll give
you the whole thing and then we'll do it.
Team Blue,
I'm going to ask you to look around and
you're going to make eye contact
with people for about ten seconds.
Team Green,
you'll be doing the same thing.
But, Team Blue,
when you make eye contact with somebody,
you're going to hold comfortable eye
contact for about ten seconds and
then I'll say switch, and
then you'll find someone else and
you'll hold comfortable eye contact
with them for about ten seconds.
And then you'll switch, you're not
going to psychotically stalk someone.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Or go after, or try to climb across,
none of that, just as I'm talking to
you right now, it's comfortable for
me to hold eye contact for this long.
It's not terribly long,
but it's a little long.
Okay, that was Team Blue.
Team Green,
You're going to also make eye contact.
But as soon as you do,
you're going to break it somehow and
then you're going to reacquire it and
then you're going to break it again.
And reacquire it as many times.
Just break and release and
break and release your eye contact.
You can move your eyes.
You can move your head.
Whatever you want.
But like they're not going to
be psychotic staring down.
You're not going to be like look,
and look away.
>> [LAUGH]
>> And look, and look away.
It's not like playing around with this.
It's just like look and break eye contact,
and then look and then you're going to
break it and look, and sort of
checking are they still looking at me?
If you match with someone two blues or
two greens together, just stay with it.
So you'll look and
you'll meet be somebody and yep, it's us.
And you know that moment of us, and
then you start doing your behavior, and
it's [SOUND]
>> [LAUGH]
>> Okay, it's whatever it is.
All right, you ready?
Turn and look for somebody.
Ten seconds.
Hold that behavior.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Look and look, or look away.
>> Great.
Switch.
Someone new,
they might be across the room.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Good.
Switch.
Okay good look up here for a second.
Great nice.
So interesting to watch.
There's something here right?
Yeah.
So switch behaviors.
Whatever you just did, do the opposite.
If you were looking, look away.
You're just going to look and hold
comfortable, don't go psychotic on us.
And if you literally or figuratively,
although literally means figuratively now.
>> [LAUGH]
>> I don't know why.
And if you were looking and looking away,
now just comfortably hold eye contact.
10 seconds.
Find someone.
Go.
And switch.
Okay.
Good, good.
Have a seat and
a short discussion about what you noticed.
>> [INAUDIBLE]
>> Huh?
>> No, nobody wants to look at me.
Yeah.
All right.
So there is something going on in that,
isn't there?
Eye contact, turns out,
means a lot to us, and
that's a pretty extreme version of it,
to just look, and hold.
It's a pretty extreme.
There's a point where it gets,
yeah, uncomfortable.
>> [LAUGH]
>> All right?
And blinking, yeah.
Yeah, really good actors,
of which I am not have trained
themselves to not blink at all.
Clint Eastwood never blinks.
And his characters tend
to be very powerful.
That's part of this.
So this equation of looking and holding,
we would call that high status.
If we drift a little from the social
science into the theater world,
we would call it high status.
And that is being more authoritative,
more powerful.
The looking and
looking away would be more approachable.
So it's authoritative versus approachable,
is the scale I think we're playing with.
If there are a set of other
behaviors that go with them and
did you notice what your body was
doing when you had the eye behaviors?
Did anybody see that?
Any observations?
>> [INAUDIBLE]
>> Yes, she when I was looking and
looking away I almost felt like I was
flirting with the woman in front of me.
That is no coincidence.
Flirting, this is another area that we're
going to go lightly over, but it for
sure shows up in the dating world of
what flirting means, and looking and
looking away can be just nervous,
but it can also be something else.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Right?
And the fact that you're all laughing
means you know how to read this.
I told you were experts.
So it's learning to navigate that.
So for sure it can feel like flirting or
it can feel like nervousness.
How we come across to each other.
Did anybody start to come up with
a little narrative or a little story
about who that person was or what they
were like just based on the eye contact?
Anybody?
Yeah.
It just happens.
If someone shows up in a way
with certain behaviors,
after a while you have to just start
to ascribe that's the kind of person.
As it turns out, and this is not great
news for smart people like yourselves.
It's not about what you say.
It is about how you say it.
And that seems unjust in a way,
but it's true.
And it does explain some
of our political landscape.
>> [LAUGH]
>> There are people who
just say it in a way that
people are attracted to.
And there are people on both sides,
of all of the possible aisles that you
could think of, that it's true for.
But it's why we do see people
coming from Hollywood and
actors that end up doing quite well.
Because they are really
good at this equation.
So, okay, it is not what you say,
it is how you say it.
It's almost like I knew
we were going there.
I would like you to, from your seat,
pick one of these two quotes.
And just read it out to the world, to me.
Either one.
Go ahead and do that now, please.
>> [INAUDIBLE]
>> Great.
So whichever one that you did
just sort of stick with that.
We're going to play
with this a little bit.
Now we're going to read it but
slightly differently.
I want you to read it in a way that
how you say it adds to the meaning.
For instance, I could say
the right word may be effective.
But no word was ever as effective
as a rightly timed pause.
That's reading it.
But the right word may be effective.
But no word is as effective
as a rightly timed pause.
That adds some meaning to
it by just how I say it.
It's different, yeah?
Your turn.
Pick the same one.
Read it in a way that it enhances meaning.
Go ahead.
>> [INAUDIBLE]
>> Nice.
>> [LAUGH]
>> The music of that is different.
Like from here I can hear it all together,
but it's much more interesting and
nuanced.
So lovely, you're great.
Okay.
This is either going to be the most fun or
the worst part of this lecture.
>> [LAUGH]
>> This is the last time I will ask it,
but please rise.
Again, I know.
Our students do complain
slightly sometimes about this,
but then end up loving this part.
So it's fun.
I'm going to invite you to all just,
to go into the fun of this one.
So I'm going to ask you
to read these again, but
I'm going to give you some archetypes.
So you're going to read them,
and I will demo them first.
I'm not going to ask you
to do anything I won't do.
You do not have to do
it quite as big as me.
I'm going to go for
it to try to open things up for you.
But you're going to read these four
times as different characters.
The first one is going
to be as the rock star.
>> [LAUGH]
>> You're physically bold, and aggressive,
and energetic.
Vocally, you're loud,
you're intense, and you're musical.
And your presence is legendary,
iconic, narcissistic and shocking!
>> [LAUGH]
>> Read your quote as the rock star, go.
>> [CROSSTALK]
[APPLAUSE]
>> I may have the best job in the world.
>> [LAUGH]
>> That was phenomenal.
>> I am going to shame our MBA
students with your enthusiasm and
say you gotta do as good as the alum did.
Now.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Read your quote as the preschool
teacher.
You're physically light and
flowing, exaggerated.
You're vocally use long vowels.
You're expressive.
You're enunciated, you're soft,
and you're sing-song.
And your presence is friendly,
and nice, and condescending.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Preschool teacher, go!
[CROSSTALK]
>> Before there is
an uprising of preschool
teachers rushing the stage,
my mother was a preschool teacher,
and I've gotten approval for this.
This is a stereotype, but
it's not who you really are.
I know that.
Okay.
We don't want angry
preschool teachers on stage.
Okay, now read it as royalty.
You are graceful, formal,
still and flowing, physically.
Vocally, it's understanding and
respectful, articulate and lyrical.
And your presence is regal.
Grounded, elevated, and majestic.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Royalty.
>> [CROSSTALK]
>> Wow.
Okay, last one.
You are the motivational speaker!
>> [LAUGH]
>> You physically are dramatic and
precise.
You are energetic and expansive.
Vocally, you are positive,
dynamic, emphasize, enthusiastic.
You can do it.
>> [LAUGH]
>> And your presence is connected,
and divine, messianic, and uplifting.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Go.
>> [CROSSTALK]
>> Yeah.
[CROSSTALK]
>> All right,
give yourselves a big round of applause.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Go ahead and
grab a seat.
Well, I was doing all four, wasn't I?
>> No, we want to hear you do all four.
>> [LAUGH]
>> There's a request that he wants to hear
all four of them.
For time, I'll do the last one as a quote.
The right word may be effective,
but no word was ever as effective
as a rightly timed pause.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> You can do it.
Okay, hey,
our DVDs are on sale in the lobby,
and go to richmotivationalspeaker.com.
Maybe I should, wow.
So we have a few more that we go
through with the students, and
then we hand out cards
with these images on it.
Half of them say, a bigger version of you.
And it's just physically more of you.
Vocally a little bit more of you and
your presence as full as you can be.
And they secretly, they get up in front of
the class, and we guess, what were you?
And if you are a bigger you, and people
say, rock star, royalty, you're like, oh.
>> [LAUGH]
>> And if you get up, and
you're a rock star, and people are like,
a bigger you, you're like, oh.
>> [LAUGH]
>> In either case,
they find out a lot about how
do they show up to the world.
What's their natural place?
And we all have one or two of these
that are little more comfortable.
One or
two that are a little less comfortable.
I went easy on you, we have one that's
a fairy with a little wand that's all
loopy and circular that's fun,
but I'll save that for next year.
But it's about, can you align what
one of these archetypes that's in you with
whatever message you're trying to deliver?
That's the real key.
We're all all of these, for sure.
But if you're stuck in one, and
you can't get to the others,
your choices are limited by your
experience, how you were raised,
all of those experiences and
how you navigate the world.
And if you decide I gotta to be
really authoritative today, but
you can't go there,
it limits your choices.
So we're trying to expand the range, so
you can go and make the choice you want.
Because nobody wants to hear,
we're having layoffs, right?
That persona does not
match with the message.
Maybe something more like royalty
is going to be better in that case
where it's more gravitas.
But there's another one that's general,
and
I don't want to walk into my niece and
go happy birthday and frighten her.
>> [LAUGH]
>> It's what matches the message.
And we all have this wide range.
But everybody's motivational
speaker is different.
And everybody's general and rock star,
they're all their version of it.
We're talking about acting now.
Because this class is acting with power.
We've done some of the social science,
but this is the acting part.
And acting is not about pretending.
It's a really common misconception.
Acting is about finding the truth.
When you see people on television
that are bad actors, or
in movies that are bad actors, and you can
tell, it's because they're pretending.
The people who are really amazing
actors are finding the truth.
And we know from the Stanford
prison experiment and
other similar things that we've got all
of it in us including the bad stuff.
And we know from everyday
people who do amazing,
heroic things,
that we've got the light in us too.
It's just part of the human condition.
Right circumstances,
we'll all do anything.
So given that, we can access anything.
And a really amazing actor can play
an evil horrible person doing terrible
things, and
then show up as like wonderful father or
mother in the next one and
they'll both feel very truthful.
So we're not talking
about being inauthentic,
about amassing power and being like,
I'm being powerful now, right?
This is powerful.
This looks cartoonish, right?
That's no really powerful.
Really powerful is, can you be still and
comfortable in a moment where you're
having that pause that's so effective.
That's much more powerful than
the puffed up, you know, of that.
So it's about finding that truth.
And it's about being fully present and
in the moment right now.
So mindfulness and yoga are getting
sort of popular in the business realm.
It's for good reason.
As the leader, you can show up and deliver
that message with an authentic version of
how you want to be with the right level
of authoritativeness or approach-ability.
because you come in too high on authority,
and scare people way, and
they won't talk to you, and
you don't get the information you need.
So maybe you need to move a little
over on the more approachable side.
But if you're always like this and you
get people to do things by being nice and
they want to do it for you, when it's
that time, you have to stop doing that.
You need to be able to go
to that range as well.
You gotta be fully present
in the moment with people.
And you have to move off of yourself and
focus on them.
So it ends up being not about you.
It's about connecting with the other
person and showing up in the way
they need you to show up to communicate
and build those relationships.
And it's also about listening and
connecting.
This is starting to sound good.
What if everybody that you interacted with
was their authentic version of
themselves always in the moment.
They were really fully present and
they listened and connected.
Like I want to live in that world.
That's a good set of stuff.
And that's what acting can offer you.
So am I saying, go take an acting class?
Yes.
I am saying go take an acting class.
It's a great place, or an improv class.
That's where I kind of came up,
through improve.
You can go and play with all of this
stuff and experience it and it's fun, and
you'll learn something about yourself.
Because it works outside in and
inside out.
If you change your body it will
change how you feel inside.
There's a good Ted Talk by
Amy Cuddy about power poses.
It's pretty popular.
People seen that?
Yeah?
Yeah.
Expand your body and
you will feel more powerful.
Backstage, before I came on,
I was back there doing this.
>> [LAUGH]
>> I had some good music on.
I have ultimate, epic, movie themes
in Spotify and I listen to that.
Plug for Spotify I guess.
But I listen to that and
it makes me feel better.
I listen to it all the way down,
as I was driving here today, and
then expanding my body because I wanted
to show up in this way with enough energy
to muster motivational speaker and
rock star in front of you.
>> [LAUGH]
>> But the same thing works the other way.
When you're feeling something,
it shows up in your body.
When you did that eye contact experiment,
I saw lots of people shift.
The first one, they were looking and
looking away and their bodies caved in and
they were more like this.
And then they got the other one and
they're like hm.
Right?
So how you feel shows up in your body so
you can use that as an indicator.
If you noticed that you're all folded up,
you know what's going on.
You can change that by expanding
your body and change how you feel.
It's sort of like when you're young and
you're a little upset, and
you go outside and play it's because
you get your body into motion and
you're emotions change
as a result of that.
Here's the quick summary
of everything I've said.
If you want to be more authoritative,
there's five S's.
Slowness, stillness, sorry, silence,
space, stillness and symmetry.
Slowness in how you move and walk.
Silence.
We've got pause encompasses that.
Space is about the space that
you take up and what's yours and
whether you invade someone else's.
Stillness is just limiting the motion.
And symmetry means this, not this.
This is asymmetric.
And I would say this is a little bit
less powerful, but more approachable.
And this is a little bit
more authority and gravitas.
And maybe a little less approachable.
So the more you do it,
the less powerful you look.
And as I start to go a little faster
with this we move into the Fs.
You're always trying to get your words in,
just.
So you don't get interrupted.
Getting your words out fast,
because you're afraid somebody will
interrupt is a lower status place.
You have to fight for it.
If you're powerful and
you're in a place of power,
you know they're going to stop talking,
and you're going to keep going anyway.
So, they better stop.
That's a different-
>> [LAUGH]
>> All right,
that's the other side of this.
If you have to fill silence, you cannot
stand there to be an empty space.
That's more on the approachable,
but lower status side.
Giving space, if anyone can give me a word
that starts with F that means giving
space, and get out of the way, I would
love it, but for now that F is give space.
Fidgeting, especially if
you touch your face or
just those little gestures where anything
you do is a little more low status.
And folded, that's this, that's sort
of protective, and any kind of folding.
That's all lower status.
So it's more approachable, people can and
will walk up to you if you do these.
And they will stay away if you
do the others a little bit more.
These work.
Don't play recklessly late night on public
transit or BART or things with these.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Because people do react to this stuff.
And if somebody is acting tough and
a little crazy, and
you come on with that authoritative,
it goes to confrontation.
So be a little careful.
And this is generally toward
the end of the school year,
there's a lot of questions about how
should I use this in interviews.
And it is not be authoritative
put on all these things and
put on that motivational speaker and
go in.
>> [LAUGH]
>> That is not it.
It is about being comfortable and
playing with this stuff until it's in
your tool kit and it comes out naturally.
And then making the strategic
choices of how you want to show up.
And the baseline rule that I
generally say for interviews for
them is, match and go just below.
You're worth talking to,
but not threatening,
and that's a pretty good thing.
If you just want to connect with somebody,
just sort of copy them physically and
vocally and
you'll come in at a pretty even level.
>> Forfeit Space.
>> Forfeit Space, winner,
yeah, thank you, yay.
I learned something, too.
I'm going to close with this.
This is my niece, Danielle.
She is super fierce, I love her.
This is her first day body surfing and
she is not going to let go of that board.
She ends up being a little bit
more on the authoritative side.
She takes after my sister who is two
years older and I know this really well.
I see it happening and when I was young,
I saw my sister as bossy, and
I know that's not the best word anymore.
What I see now is leadership
skills in my niece.
And she's good at it,
and I help encourage it.
The problem is Brady.
[LAUGH]
And
he's the same age younger than me and
my sister.
And this is him trying really hard,
that finger outstretched and
taking up, it's invading her space,
desperately trying to exert his authority.
But can you see on his face
that it's not really there?
>> [LAUGH]
>> He knows it's coming,
and so does she,
because look at that expression.
I can't tell you the muscles that do it,
but I know the expressions is she is about
to take that away from him, and I watched
it happen because I took this picture.
[LAUGH] He tries, but he is on the more
approachable side of the world.
Kind of like his uncle.
>> [LAUGH]
>> One of the things that comes up in
this work a lot is people say, should I be
more authoritative or more approachable,
and they tend to think high power, and
that's the way to go, what we want.
But he's not wrong.
Brady is just fine and so are you if
you are on the approachable side.
And so am I.
It's not that there's a right or a wrong.
We want the most range.
And you have found your place,
your comfort zone, and
that is a great place to be.
And if you can stretch and
find few more places that you
could go one way or the other.
It might help you navigate
a few relationships.
But everybody is okay on this,
especially Brady.
[LAUGH]
>> Do have the next picture,
where she has- [LAUGH]
>> I don't, I didn't get that picture.
But it happens enough I could
go get it this weekend.
>> [LAUGH]
>> The thing that I like about this is
we learn it when we're young.
They're already experts.
So we already know it.
So hopefully I've said that,
and now you know, and
you will now see this everywhere.
You have a great opportunity
with all these cocktail parties,
and things you're going to, and events.
Just step back for awhile and
watch it all happen.
People reaching in and invading space and
putting an arm around.
All this stuff is going on,
so that's one thing.
The other is there isn't a right or wrong
that both ends of the spectrum are great.
It's about relationships, it's about
they really do get along very well.
because they navigate this.
They're figuring it out and
their going to be okay.
It's a secret language that we all speak.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE].
Do we have.
Okay, so we do have a couple
minutes if you have any questions.
We have some mics, you can come on up.
We're going a little into overtime.
>> [INAUDIBLE]
>> Yes I can, yes I can.
>> I'd like to ask you what we're
talking about is body language,
and there are people who feel
body language is more effective.
I mean, 50,60,
I have one sign that says that says 70%.
What about all of the communications
that's going on without the bodies.
The texting, the, you don't pick up any
of the meanings, the feelings, the this.
>> Yeah, okay, so
with online email, texting,
that kind of communication and chat,
yeah there's no body language involved.
We've tried.
I think it's why we have emoticons.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Right, it's trying to insert because
we're desperate for that other information
to come in so I think we try in that way.
But it definitely affects
the communication.
If you've been online at all
>> It's just a lot of arguing and
positional stuff and
I think it doesn't happen when you put two
actual people in a room because
there is a more fluid communication.
I think the relationships in person
are better than they are online.
>> I have grandchildren who feel if
you're not texting, then that's it.
You text.
Don't bother to call.
That's old fashioned.
Don't say I want me to sit down and talk.
It's texting.
>> Yes, I know.
>> So we are losing something.
>> I think we are losing something.
I think we are.
>> Thanks.
>> Great, yeah?
>> Class of '65.
>> Yeah!
>> Would you talk about
power at the species level?
How is it that our species
has got this notion
that we are the most
powerful on the planet.
By golly we deserve it, and
we can get away with whatever we want.
Is that a problem, and
how do we deal with that?
>> [LAUGH] Yeah,
we can applaud that, yeah.
I think, demonstrably, it is a problem.
There are plenty of problems
that are caused by that.
And I think it's part of why we are averse
to power, is because we as a species tend
to consume Take and
use up all of the resource.
I don't know what we can
do specifically about it.
I think from this work,
hopefully relationships and
building better relationships
is one of the keys to it.
Because we have to work together.
We're quickly growing to the point
where there's not much left,
and we're going to have to work together.
And I think this is one key to it.
I go all over the world teaching and
working with this, and
it's the same, it's universal.
The space, we talk about space and
invading space.
It's different in different cultures.
How much space is okay to be
between you is different.
But what's universal is,
if I cross that line whatever
distance it is, that's dominant.
So there are some universal things and
I think it can help
improve our communication.
But I wish I had a save
the world message for you, yes.
>> Richmond, you're talking about.
>> Hi.
>> How are you doing?
When you're talking about authoritative,
you mentioned taking up space and
also being silent.
And I'm wondering about,
there's an apparent tension
that sometimes people who
are authoritative take up vocal space.
>> Oh, yes.
>> And
can you say a little bit more
about how those two work together?
>> Yes, I mean,
space works physically and vocally.
People that dominate a conversation and
don't leave room,
that's an act of dominance and power.
I was just watching
Bill Maher's television show.
And there was woman sat
between two men and
the one on the left was incredibly
dominating, interrupted her so many times.
And she did some beautiful moves.
In the middle of doing
it to help affect that.
One, he started talking and she just put
her hand out and rested it on his arm and
left it there, until she stopped talking.
And it shut up him up.
It was very subtle but it was dominating.
It was just like that cat paw on there.
>> [LAUGH]
>> To do that.
And the second one is she started talking,
and he interrupted and she said, oh,
you know where I'm going?
>> [LAUGH]
>> And then let him go.
And she kind of claimed the vocal
space that this is my idea, but
I'll let you say it.
And so I thought those were really,
really evolved and
nice ways of dealing with that
situation because it comes up a lot.
Yeah, yeah, I'm going to go over here and
then I'll come back, yeah.
>> I know you didn't wan to
get into the gender stuff.
>> Yes?
>> But I have to ask if you
have any thoughts, insights,
interesting research about the negative
consequences of power in women.
>> Yes, look at me distance myself.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Wow, that's what I mean.
You can watch your own body language and
realize what's going on.
Okay, let me step into this.
So I get to, I'm lucky enough to teach
with Professor Deb Rumfeld here,
and she has some fantastic
research about gender in this.
She's working on a book so
there's going to be more soon.
One of the things is that there is
a warmth competence gap for women.
That the perception of men and
the perception of women, on men,
is that the warmer they are,
the more competent they are.
And the more competent they are,
the warmer they are.
The perception of both men and women on
women, is that the more warm they are,
the less competent, and
the more competent, the less warm.
And that is not a great
piece of data that we have.
But it is a true piece of data that's
observational and not prescriptive.
But, and I think this is not
news to the women in the room.
Have you experienced this?
Yeah, yeah.
So, what can we do about it?
Society has to change for
that gap to close.
But with this, having the widest
authentic range, and being able to
be fluid across it and make choices,
I think is the best way of doing it.
It turns out it's the best thing for
men, as well.
But that is the most effective
is to be dynamic in that.
The trap that came up,
sort of in the 80s and
90s, was thinking that you
have to make a choice.
And it's like,
well I'm going to make my career path, and
I'm going to be competent, and
I don't care what they think.
And that's a valid choice, and
you know, you can go with that, but
I think it doesn't have to be so
one end or the other.
So that's a piece of it,
one of the ones we have the most data on.
Yeah, you're welcome.
>> [INAUDIBLE]
>> Okay, great.
>> Okay, so I'm thinking that
it's good to be fluid and
to be able to move in different spectrums.
But if we find ourselves, let's say
at low status, low warmth, weak and
repellent, is there a I'm okay,
you're okay, is that okay?
>> [LAUGH]
>> They're all okay.
It's what is the relationship and
how you want to cross and
does it match with what your saying.
Where I think this shows up is
sometimes we're just unaware of
where we're showing up or
how we are showing up.
And it can be as simple as you walk in,
a bad commute and not feeling that great.
And you can be sort of down, low and cold.
And that's what you're putting off.
And if you know that that's a possibility,
then when you hit the door, you can say,
is that how I want to show up?
And, it's okay to go, yup.
I feel terrible, and stay away.
And, go ahead and do that.
But, you can also stop at the door and
go, okay, it's an important meeting.
I'm going to put this on now, and
by putting it on I'll start to feel it and
go and have that moment.
So, making choices.
This is a little generalized.
There's a large, nuanced conversation.
The main idea is that there's
authoritative and approachable, but
there's also warm and cold on both.
So yeah, thank you.
Yes, last one.
Yeah.
>> Yes, can you take Roosevelt, Churchill,
Reagan, Bill Clinton, and tell them, and
tell us where you would place them in the-
>> [LAUGH]
>> That is a great question and
actually that is what we do with this in
our classes, we get from the students
who's in these quadrants and go through
them and those names frequently come up.
Oprah comes up,
up in that top one as well, often.
So I would be guessing on a few of those
because I'm an organizational behavior
lecturer and not a history one.
So I don't know the depth of them.
But powerful leaders tend
to be on the higher side,
and then they vary from warm to cold.
I would say Bill Clinton
is on the warm side.
>> [LAUGH]
>> And
Vladimir Putin is on the colder side.
>> [LAUGH]
>> So there is a range.
Both leaders, both powerful.
Both got things done.
So, that is another piece of this,
is, again, neither one is right.
You can be a leader and be authoritative
and cold, and you can be a leader and
be more warm, and they both work.
>> Speaking style, royalty,
you know, motivational speaker,
in that grouping any easy
placement of those presidents?
>> Generally, high status and
I would say, varied on warmth.
Churchill's a little before me, but my,
the images and things that I have seen,
seems a little cold.
Seems a little on the cooler side,
and more stoic.
>> [INAUDIBLE]
>> It
might be more royalty, yeah, yeah, great.
Thank you.
>> Great.
>> Thank you, Emily.
[MUSIC]